hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
from mkbhd and this is a short giveaway
entry video for the folks at gearlab.com
and youtube.com gearlive and this is my
entry into their hp envy 13 contest and
they want me to tell a little bit about
what i would do with this laptop should
i be the winner should i win this
13-inch laptop the primary thing that
i'll be doing with this laptop is
keeping up with what i do here on my
youtube channel which is primarily
education i do a number of unboxing
videos related tech videos and also
hardware videos as well as screencasts
what i would do on this machine is keep
up with my email keep up with twitter
and keep up with all the comments posted
on my video as people continue to
message me asking questions i will
continue to answer them
so having a machine so thin and so
portable is definitely something that's
going to help me answer people's
questions help their fits and problems
wherever they are on the go and this
will definitely be a big help for this
youtube channel and to this community so
thanks for giving the opportunity gear
live for anyone to win the hp envy
13-inch and i'm glad to submit my entry
so thanks for watching and mkbhd signing
out peace